[MUSIC PLAYING]
TIM KELTON: Welcome
to Planet Scale,
Making Planet Scale
Geospatial Processing Possible
with BigQuery GIS.
This morning, we've got
a really exciting show.
We have two types of geospatial
modeling in food supply.
And it's before lunch.
So these are going to be kind
of the grains and the foods--
and the proteins, I guess.
So on the first on the
top path across the top,
it's going to be Descartes Labs.
I am one of the co-founders
of Descartes Labs
and how we leverage our
Descartes Labs platform
for Machine Learning for
modeling various grain
productions across
the United States.
And then we need to ship
those grains around the world.
And so how would you start
to model and understand
shipping, and supply
chain logistics,
and those types of challenges?
Then David's going
to come up, and he'll
be focusing more on the protein
side of things and fishing.
David's from Global
Fishing Watch,
and he's going to talk
about how they leverage
Earth Engine to
observe and track
vessels for illegal fishing.
So where these two
workflows come together
is on a common vector
data set, excuse me.
And that's called AIS.
If you're not familiar
with AIS, that's
Automatic Identification
System for how
ships send their location
to avoid collisions.
And both Descartes Labs
and Global Fishing Watch
are both using
BigQuery as a place
to put these massive amounts
of AIS data into BigQuery.
And that, of course, is
Google's serverless managed data
warehouse.
And so no matter how many
billions and billions
of rows of AIS data
either of us get,
we're not worried about
BigQuery being able to scale up
or to be able to run
our queries to provide
that type of analysis.
Then finally, for our really
exciting finale, we have Mosha.
And Mosha is the chief
BigQuery officer.
So I don't know how you get the
chief BigQuery officer title,
but what's really cool
is he's going to show us
behind the scenes
how Google built
these geospatial functions.
So that's really
going to be exciting.
So it's been announced
that BigQuery geospatial is
launching today for
general availability.
This is the only
cloud data warehouse
that has first class support
for GIS functions and GIS data
types.
So that means that
GIS functions are now
backed by the full force of
the BigQuery team and BigQuery
service level agreements.
So that helps me
at Descartes Labs
write service level agreements
and make sure I can get support
and serve my customers.
And so you might
say, well, what's
new since the beta, those of
you that have been in the beta.
I'll let you read through
all of these features,
but I'll tell you about
the two that we're
leveraging at Descartes Labs.
We've really seen
big improvements
from the ability of
the speed of JOINs,
and how fast JOINs are running,
and we do a lot of that.
So that's been a big difference.
And then ST_GeogFromText,
that's really useful for us
for ingesting large polygons.
So those are two that
are useful for us.
I'm sure everyone has
different workflows.
Descartes Labs, if you're
not familiar with us,
we were founded in 2014.
And we're kind of this anomaly
in the startup world, I guess.
We're not in the Bay Area.
We do have an office
here and in New York,
but we're up in the mountains
of Santa Fe, New Mexico, where
I can get a quick ski
lap in before heading
into the office in the morning.
And we've been around for
a little over four years.
And the reason we're
up in the mountains
is because myself and the
rest of the founding team
were scientists, and
researchers, and engineers
at Los Alamos
National Laboratory.
And there we focused on our
expertise areas such as--
sorry, I'll go back--
machine learning,
remote sensing,
and kind of understanding how
changes impact the planet.
So we leverage massive
amounts of satellite data
to build those types of models
to see what insights might
impact our customers,
their supply chain, all
of their logistics,
and how can we
help them become more efficient.
We leverage a wide range
of GCP infrastructure
to build our multi-tenant
machine learning SaaS platform.
And we originally built all
of this for our own team
and how to make our team as
effective and productive as
possible to be able to
really rapidly iterate
on machine learning models
and train them, get results,
tweak the models,
retest, re-validate,
and how can we do that
in hyper efficiency.
And we've since
externalized that
to a lot of different
customers who have ideas
besides just what we've done.
And one of the benefits of GCP
is these are all microservices
based.
And there's all types of
persistent data stores
that I can mix and
match each microservice
to just pick the right
persistence layer for that.
And just like with
microservices,
you might want to--
with remote sensing,
we also have
to select the right use
case for the right data set
and be able to fuse
those all together
to come up with insights
that actually matter.
So one of the
fundamental challenges
is being able to combine these
data sets for the problem.
It's not usually just
one data set gives us
the straight answer.
And I think you're going to
see that from both of us today.
And so when I say satellites,
most people will think--
and with satellites
tracking ships,
I would guess a lot of you might
think this beautiful picture
of a ship on the ocean.
And we look at this in
red, green, blue, kind
of the left column or the
left part of this diagram.
But often, there's
a problem with this.
There's a pesky
thing called clouds,
and I'm not talking
about cloud computing.
It's clouds getting in between
the satellite and the Earth.
And so those can
abstract our view.
So sometimes it works,
and sometimes we
get really good
insights from that.
But sometimes we have to look
at other types of sensors.
So if we move to the
middle of this diagram,
we see another type of sensor
called synthetic aperture
radar.
And an example of this is from
the European Space Agency.
We have a satellite
called Sentinel-1.
What this does is it
sends a radar signal.
The satellite itself sends a
radar signal off the Earth.
It bounces off the Earth.
And then the satellite receives
that signal on another orbit.
This is great because
it penetrates right
through clouds.
So that's problem solved, except
the refresh rates aren't always
really helpful when you're
tracking global supply
chains like shipping.
And so that brings us
to this third data set.
And that's AIS.
And so these ships are
sending a message or a ping
to a ground station,
and the satellites
are able to see and locate where
those radio frequencies were
transmitted from.
So lots of pictures
in this talk.
I hope you're already-- and
that's fine with everyone.
It's GIS, so it's very
visual crowd here.
On the left, we
would have the types
of the different
bands of light that we
would use for modeling
agricultural crops.
So you can see the
bright green and purple
is showing basically
photosynthesis
and where it's occurring
in the crop health.
So we're able to build models
that kind of predict the yield.
When we move over right one and
we see that synthetic aperture
radar, what you're actually
seeing the differentiation
there is the fields
that have been recently
plowed and slightly disturbed.
That's the types of things
we can see with Sentinel-1.
Then you have clay
minerals ratio.
And then finally,
on the far right,
we have high resolution human
visible red, green, and blue
spectrums of light.
So that's things we
would use for our more
kind of computer vision
or TensorFlow type models.
That would be things like
maybe detecting oil pads,
in this case.
So we work all over the world.
We build crop models
all over the world
for all different
types of crops.
In this talk, I can only kind of
go into a little bit of detail
about one, and I'll
talk about corn.
And you might say, well, what's
this machine learning model of?
Well, I think the only
thing this could detect
is the state of Iowa and
maybe the city of Des Moines.
But it probably isn't useful
for classifying much else really
in this example.
But we have a lot of really
complicated processing steps
to get to that point.
We have to be able to
identify and segment out
all the different fields.
We have to know what's
like an urban area
because we don't want to
include those geographic areas
into our models.
Then we finally have to
run a classifier to say
is this a cornfield, a wheat
field, a soybean field,
those types of things.
And so then after we had
those types of information,
then we can finally start
to estimate how much food
is being produced in every
single one of those fields
and roll that up into various--
the state level, the county
level, and national level to be
able to model the overall food
supply and how this
year's crop production is
going to come onto the market.
And then we'll back test
this for 10 or 15 years,
seeing every single farm
everywhere in the US every day
and then saying how did that
model do in that drought year
or in that year we
had flooding in Iowa.
And test the model at day 200.
How did it do?
So and then we'll
constantly iterate
on that to try and make those
models as accurate as we can.
So that gives us
an idea how much
food is being produced at
what parts of the country.
But one of the next
things is often
that's not where it's
getting delivered to.
It's going to somewhere
else in the world.
So problems we
have to think about
are what about rail capacity?
How do you get from the
field or the elevator
to the river where
you would have barges?
And those barges would
take these commodities
down the river.
Then there's traffic
and traffic delays
on places like the Mississippi
River, believe it or not.
How busy are they?
Is there delays at the port?
Is weather going to
impact those routes?
Are the delays in places
like the Panama Canal?
Can I reroute and get a
more efficient speed up
or better fuel efficiency,
those types of things.
So here's on the bottom,
we're showing optical.
So that's the human visible red,
green, blue beautiful pictures
that we talked about.
And on the top, we
see the AIS route,
and that works even
with cloud cover.
So AIS, let's dive a
little bit more into that.
What is it?
It's automatic
identification system.
So this is the message
that ships are sending out
to avoid collisions.
It's sending their unique
ID, where their position,
where the course is.
And they send kind of--
it's a ping message at given
intervals to tell each other
and track so they
don't all collide.
And this data set, like almost
any type of sensor data,
we're seeing this just
explode dramatically.
A single AIS vendor from
just Descartes Labs,
just one vendor we use captures
tens of billions of AIS pings
a day.
And so what's
happening is we are
having this explosion in space.
And as satellites go from
these research devices built
by NASA that cost a half
billion dollars to things
that grad departments are
building for a few thousand
dollars and they're getting
cheaper to put into space,
that global coverage is
getting quicker and quicker.
So you're just seeing
this infinite growth.
So that's where
having a no ops--
I don't have to add disks, or
capacity, or processing cores
to be able to ingest
that data starts
to become really valuable.
So here's a global
visualization just to show you
the traffic patterns.
And about 90% of global trade is
actually done over the oceans.
So as you recall, we are
showing corn yields in Iowa,
where the next thing is being
able to model and predict
how delays or impacts on
those barges going down
the waterways in the US, where
those delays are happening
and how things are progressing.
It's not that
different than if there
was a delay getting off
the Bay Bridge on your way
here this morning.
But this is for shipping.
And over the past few months
or over just a few months,
we queried--
I think this was a query over
four months on the Mississippi
River.
This is showing we were
able to query down and see
that there was a little
over 350,000 ping messages
for ships.
On a like larger
scale, OK, what's
happening when they get down to
the bottom of the Mississippi?
So this is looking at ships
that were in New Orleans
and also in the Panama Canal
and where were they going.
And so this is what used to
be an incredibly hard query
to actually execute, and
it would be really hard
if we were doing this in
other types of databases.
Because it's just an
incredibly long running query.
So finally, then what
happens when we start
to get into the Panama Canal?
So in this scene, we're showing
synthetic aperture radar.
And you're able to see the
ships starting to line up
outside of the Panama Canal.
And that's sending
that radar signal down,
and you'll be able
to see the difference
in the purple and green.
And you see the ships out there
and how that signal reflects
off the water.
And but again, remember
the problem here
is we're only passing over
this spot in the Earth
every few days.
So it's not very high
temporal cadence.
So we need something better.
So again, that's where
we go back to things
like being able put this data
into AIS and being able to--
this AIS data set
into a queriable form.
And then we can start
to see the Panama
Canal in much closer to real
time with many, many data
points.
And you can see ships
waiting on both the Atlantic
and the Pacific side.
To the left colored
in dark is wherever
ships have really slowed down.
And you can see kind of two
congestion zones in the Panama
Canal, and then the green we're
seeing where ships are moving
at a much, much quicker rate.
So these are the types
of models and insights
we're trying to build for our
customers to really enable
them to make better decisions
on their shipping, and supply
chain, and logistics, and
impact their business.
And so that's great for
grain and grain modeling.
But the next, we're going
to turn it over to David,
and he's going to
talk about fishing.
DAVID KROODSMA: Thank you, Tim.
Hi, my name is David Kroodsma.
And I am the director of
research and innovation
at Global Fishing Watch.
And I'm going to share with
you a similar workflow where
we take radar imagery from
Sentinel-1 across the globe,
process it using Google Earth
Engine to identify where
we think there are vessels
all over the globe,
and then combine that with
AIS data using spatial
BigQuery to identify
where we think all
the world's fishing vessels
that are not broadcasting
their location are.
So I work for Global
Fishing Watch.
Global Fishing Watch, we're an
independent nonprofit dedicated
to improving transparency in
the industrial fishing industry.
We were originally
founded in 2014
by Google and two nonprofits,
Sky Truth and Google,
although now we are
our own nonprofit,
and we are entirely
foundation supported.
We have about 30 staff
globally distributed,
although we do meet
up every now and then.
And we have almost 40,000
registered map users
that go to our website,
globalfishingwatch.org,
which you can visit, and look at
our interactive map of fishing
activity.
So our goal is to increase
transparency in the world's
fishing industry.
And when most of us
think of fishing,
this is what we think of.
However, this is
not the fishing we
are trying to track at
Global Fishing Watch.
We are trying to track fishing
that looks much more like this.
So this is a picture
from China at the end
of their summer at a port
where fishing vessels
are leaving the fish.
And the way China
manages its fisheries
is that during the summer,
there is a three month--
actually now a four
month moratorium
where no fishing is allowed.
And at the end of
that, all these vessels
are allowed to go out and fish.
So if you're a fish, this is
what's coming out for you.
And you can zoom out and just
see the scale of this fleet.
And China does have the
world's largest fleet,
but this is not just China.
We are fishing all
the world's oceans
using large industrial
vessels to catch fish.
And of course, we eat
this fish, but that's
how we're fishing the oceans.
And what we've done at
Global Fishing Watch
is zoomed out one more time,
using all of that position data
from AIS to map all of
the fishing activity
by large industrial
vessels that have AIS.
AIS, as Tim
mentioned, is a system
by which vessels broadcast their
location so that other vessels
can see where they are.
And it's only required
on large vessels,
so again, we're only
seeing the large ones here,
but we can track what
their activity is.
So you may ask, so
why does this matter?
I mean, it looks
exciting, but why do we
care about transparency
in fisheries?
Here's why.
Over a billion
people in the world
depend on fish for their
primary source of protein.
Yet, one in third fisheries
are overfished globally.
And about one in
five fish are caught
through means that are illegal,
unreported, or unregulated.
So in summary, fish is
critical to the global food
supply, especially some of the
poorer people on the planet,
yet it has a high
ecological cost.
We're not doing it sustainably.
And we're monitoring
it extremely poorly.
And it's also
involved in a lot--
there's also a lot of crime
and illegal activity associated
with it.
So our belief is that if we
can track fishing activity more
efficiently, make
it more transparent,
we can make it both
more sustainable
and also provide
food for people.
How do we do it?
So our key technology is
we use two machine learning
algorithms, two neural nets,
to identify fishing activity.
And if you look at-- these
are showing the tracks
of a trawler, which is
a type of vessel that
drags nets behind it,
a longliner, which
sets long lines of hooks,
and a purse seiner, which
circles fish with a net.
And these are the
tracks from the AIS data
we just plot how they move.
And you can see with
your eye how differently
each of these vessels move.
So we're able to train a
classifier that guesses
based solely on how the boat
is moving what type of vessel
it is.
We also can tell what
are non-fishing vessels,
so identify what are
the tugboats, what
are the tankers, what are
the passenger vessels.
So that we can
ignore those and just
look at the fishing vessels.
We then have a second
model, which is,
based on how these boats
move, what is the likelihood
that it's fishing?
We put those two
together onto a map,
and we're able to make a
global map of fishing activity
by these vessels.
And here it is for
one year of activity.
And this is probably the biggest
I have ever projected this map,
although I have looked
at this many, many times.
I love this map.
It's beautiful to look at.
It's exciting.
You see all types of--
I see new things every
time I look at it.
But it's not just a pretty map.
Creating this global data
set of fishing activity
has had real impacts.
In addition to being the first
ever global map of fishing
activity, the data
has been used to help
identify six places for
marine protected areas, which
has an area the size of Egypt.
We've gotten a few countries,
including Indonesia, Peru,
and Panama, with Indonesia
and Peru two of the top five
fishing countries in the world
to commit to transparency.
In the last three
years, our data set
and our research
partners have produced
over 20 peer reviewed papers.
And one of these
papers identified how,
looking at how boats fish,
identified how subsidies
are helping drive overfishing.
And so that has led to an
engagement with the World Trade
Organization, where our data
is being used in negotiations
to identify how we
can change $20 billion
in fishery subsidies,
a lot of which
drive and promote overfishing.
So this is really exciting.
It's really great what
we've been able to do.
But there's one
problem, which is
that not all the boats
broadcast their location
and also some of them don't
broadcast the right location.
So, so far, we have
tracked the positions
of all vessels voluntarily
broadcasting their positions.
What about vessels that
tamper with their AIS device
or broadcast wrong positions?
So as sort of a
reminder, the way
we're telling where
these boats go
is that there is a GPS device on
these vessels with a radio that
then broadcasts the latitude,
longitude, timestamp
and a few other characteristics
to other boats nearby
and then also to satellites.
Some vessels have changed
the latitude and longitude
that they're broadcasting so
it says they're somewhere else.
We're not sure why some
of them are doing this,
but some of them
are, and the result
is you get wrong
positions in the data.
Here's a great example.
Down there on the
bottom left of this,
you see a boat says it's
in the Southern Pacific.
Then it says it goes south
through Antarctica, then goes
to negative 95 degrees
south, which is impossible,
and then back up.
It's not there.
It is actually up there
close to the coast of Peru
going around South America.
And we need some automatic
way to identify this.
And one thing we do know is
we know when each message is
received by a satellite, and
we know where the satellite is
when it receives that message.
And so we can look
at the position
of the satellite,
which usually has
to be within about 3,000
kilometers of the boat
to receive a message, to say
roughly where in the world
it is.
But it turns out you get a much
more accurate estimate of where
that boat is if you take the
average position of satellites
that receive the messages
at the times they receive
the message over a given day.
So what you want
to do is you want
to take the average
position of lat
and long over a day of a
vessel and then the average lat
and long of the satellite
positions over a day
and compare them.
So you need to
average lat and long.
That's actually very
tricky on a sphere.
And before spatial BigQuery,
we did something like this.
Oh yeah, so the vessel's
actually up there.
Before spatial
BigQuery, did something
like this, which is a lot
of trigonometry to turn
the latitude and longitude
into x, y, and z,
and then average
the x, y, and z,
and then turn them back
into latitude and longitude.
And it took 32 lines of SQL.
And with spatial BigQuery,
we are now able to do this.
And just the key calculation
is just one line,
where we turn st_centroid_agg
from the latitude and longitude
of all the points
for a given day
and then are able to get where
that average location is.
So the one thing I
failed to say earlier
is that all of our AIS
data is in BigQuery.
And we use it every day to use
to do almost every analysis
on what boats are doing.
And it has been
incredibly useful
in every way of analysis.
And now, we started using
it before spatial functions.
And there's tons of cases
where we figured out
a really hard way
to do something,
and it turns out this
spatial BigQuery can now
save us tons of time
and effort and also
allow us to do things
we weren't able to do.
Simple things like
just calculating
the distance between points
is so much easier now.
So here's one example.
So we can identify these
vessels more easily
that have their offset
in their position.
But there's a bigger
problem, which
is that most fishing vessels
don't broadcast their AIS.
We call this the dark fleet.
And a lot of them aren't
regulated to carry it,
so they don't have to.
But you can also
imagine that if you
want to engage in
an illegal activity,
you are most likely
not to broadcast AIS.
So we want to see these boats.
How can we do it?
Well, one thing we
can do is use radar.
So as Tim talked about, there's
a satellite called Sentinel-1
from the European Space
Agency that has radar.
And the radar can penetrate
clouds and see bright objects
on water.
So this is a composite
image over several months.
If you look between the
United Kingdom and Europe--
that's what you're
looking there,
at the English Channel--
you can see all those dots.
That's the shipping lanes.
And that's because metal
objects on water show up.
It's really bright in radar.
And what we can do is we
can look at these scenes,
and we can count where
there are likely vessels.
Sentinel-1 is the
satellite we're using,
and it covers all the
world's terrestrial service.
It doesn't do the
oceans, but it does
do all the world's coastlines.
And most vessels
are close to shore.
So what we've done
is we said, OK, we're
going to process all
of the Sentinel-1 that
overlaps with the coastlines.
That's a few 100,000 images
and over a petabyte of data.
How do we process a
petabyte of radar imagery?
As I said, we're
a small nonprofit.
We don't have tons of
servers sitting around.
But we do have
Google Earth Engine.
And Google Earth
Engine has two features
that make it extremely
useful for us.
The first is that they
have-- it's a data catalog.
And so they've organized
satellite imagery
from tons of the most useful
freely available satellite
archives, including, say,
the entire-- and they have
the entire Sentinel-1 archive
just sitting there in servers
so that we don't need to
download and pre-process it.
Then built on top
of that, there's
a computational
platform that allows
you to do analyses
at scale distributed
across all of these images.
So we can figure out a process
for one image from Sentinel-1
and then hit Run and run
it across the whole globe.
Here's a picture of what
the viewer of it looks like.
So there's a nice JavaScript.
There's a nice web based
JavaScript editor here
at the top.
You can see you can edit
your code and share it.
It has an interactive map that
you can look at and work on.
And so you can kind
of play with it
and see what images look like
as you're analyzing them.
And then run.
There's also a Python API.
And so we use the
JavaScript tool
to kind of do the
inspections, write the code,
and then we move it over
and use the Python API when
we want to put it
into production to run
across the whole globe,
although you can also
do some of that in the
JavaScript console.
So let's look at one of
these Sentinel-1 scenes.
Let's zoom in.
So this is what it looks like.
The one you're looking on
the left there is Italy.
On the right is Croatia.
This is in the Adriatic Sea.
It's about 200 miles
across, is one scene.
The dark area there is
the footprint of the scene
that we have analyzed.
And all of those dots
are where our algorithm--
that we use in Earth
Engine is just looking
for bright spots on the water--
says that there are
probably vessels on vessels.
Now we want to compare this
with the AIS data, which is also
in BigQuery, to say
which of these dots
are fishing boats, which of
these are not fishing boats,
and which of these are
vessels that do not have AIS.
To do that's a
little complicated
because you can imagine
the satellite images
taken at one time.
And then your AIS
positions aren't always
exactly at the point
of the satellite.
They may be a little bit before.
They may be a little bit after.
And you need to do some smart
interpolation between those two
points to get the most
likely position of the vessel
at the time of the satellite to
match it to these detections.
Also, you want to clip
it to just this scene
so you compare it to only
the scene you're looking at.
And I don't have to process and
compare all the points outside.
So what we've done is we've
loaded all of this information
into BigQuery from the
output of Earth Engine.
So we take the output of
Earth Engine, which gives us
all of these positions
messages, and then also we
take the outline of the
footprint, so a polygon
of the footprint of that image.
And we upload the
footprint, that
footprint as a well-known
text into BigQuery,
as well as all these detections.
And then we can do a
JOIN on the AIS data.
So we interpolate
the AIS data and then
do an ST contains
for points that
are within the footprint of the
satellite at the right position
to identify which vessels
are most likely to match up
with which detections
from radar.
And in this scene, lots
of vessels use AIS.
So we can match it quite well.
And so the red dots there
are things that we think
are fishing vessels.
The turquoise ones are ones
that are non-fishing vessels.
And the gray ones are ones
that were not matched.
They could be
objects in the water.
We're identifying
those another way.
But a lot of them are vessels
that do not broadcast AIS.
Zoom out to the
entire Adriatic Sea.
You can see Italy's
on the left there.
And to the right is the
former Yugoslavian countries.
And then in the south is Greece.
And this is all the detections
over one year in this area.
And you can see
the shipping lanes.
You can see some
fishing activity.
And we now are able to
put all this into BigQuery
and match it at scale to
identify which of these we
think are non-fishing vessels,
which of these are fishing
vessels, and which of
these are not matched.
If you look on the
right on the east coast
there, on the east side of the
sea close to what is Albania,
you'll see a bunch
of gray activity.
Albania does not require
its fleet to carry AIS.
So that could be
the fishing fleet.
And we've done one
more thing here,
which is we have trained a
model to identify based solely
on where an object
is in the ocean,
using features such as
the bathymetry, the slope
of the bathymetry,
whether or not
it's close to a shipping
lane, the distance from shore.
All these features which we
actually generated with JOINs
in BigQuery, we use those
features on each observation
and are able to make a guess
about whether it's a fishing
boat or a non-fishing vessel.
I've also added in the bottom
here a dotted line here,
that yellow dotted
line, which is
the area of a proposed
marine protected area.
Sorry.
So we trained a model,
and we're able to guess
with some confidence,
some probabilistically,
that those red dots are
likely fishing vessels.
So you can see that's a dark
fleet of fishing vessels
there on the right side
that are not broadcasting.
Why does this matter?
Well, the yellow
dotted line there
is a marine
protected area that's
been proposed in the
southern Adriatic.
And so we had a nonprofit in
Europe come to us and say,
can you tell us what fishing
activity is happening
within this proposed area?
Because we want to talk
with the fishing industry
and have negotiations
about where
this marine protected area
will be, how much fishing
will be affected by it.
And we don't know how
much fishing is there.
So we're able to use
this method to then--
now let's zoom into that area.
And there's a bunch of fishing
on the west side on the left
that you can't see because it's
underneath the turquoise dots.
And let's just look at
the fishing and zoom in.
And we're able to say that is
the fishing activity over 2017
of vessels within that proposed
area, which is now extremely
useful for having those
discussions about where to site
this marine protected area.
So again, we're trying to create
transparency in the world's
fishing industry.
Being able to use
spatial BigQuery
has been a huge assist
to us because we
spend so much of our time
in BigQuery analyzing
data, processing things.
And these functions have
allowed us to really get
another few steps forward
in creating transparency
in fishing.
And the reason we want to
create transparency in fishing
is because we want
more places like this.
This is a real picture taken by
one of our research partners'
teams, Enric Sala of National
Geographic Pristine Seas, that
shows off a marine
protected area that
has an incredible
abundance of sharks.
And our goal is to protect--
have as many places like
this as we can in the world.
And one of the ways we can
do that is to illuminate
the world's dark
fleets, which we think
will help end illegal,
unreported, unregulated fishing
by industrial fishing vessels.
Thank you very much.
And now I'm going to
hand it off to Mosha, who
is the chief BigQuery engineer.
I do have to say, I've
been doing BigQuery now
for the last 3 and 1/2 years.
And I did take a
selfie with him earlier
because I was very
excited to meet
the man behind what we've been
using at Global Fishing Watch.
MOSHA PASUMANSKY: All
right, thank you, David.
So it's been really
fascinating for me
to listen to both of those
talks from Tim and David
and hear how things
that we built
into product and
to BigQuery, how
they're used in the real
world for such great causes.
So my portion of the work
is going to be about--
I will tell you how BigQuery
was able to achieve all those--
to be able to power
those applications
and to be able to do those
special analysis at such
a big scale.
So I'm going to talk
about every single detail
and every single algorithm--
well, maybe-- maybe
not every single one,
but hopefully the
most important ones--
and explain how it works.
So one little warning-- there
will be a little bit of math
in this presentation,
but nothing too hard,
nothing like high
schoolers cannot deal with.
OK, so let's start.
One of the great things
about working in Google
is that we have world expert
on about every single subject.
And of course, Google has
been doing geography-- dealing
with geography data and
location data for a very, very
long time.
We have products like Google
Maps, and Google Earth Engine,
and Google searches of
this location [INAUDIBLE],,
and Android.
And now it's really
easier to find products
which don't use locations.
So there is a lot of
expertise inside Google.
And all those products are
a little bit different.
But at the heart of all of
them, at the core of them,
is this amazing
low-level library
called S2 Geometry
Library, which
deals with very low-level
details which are also
picky details, you know,
how you do all the geometry,
and how you do it on the
surface of the Earth.
So really what we were
building was standing
on the shoulders of giants.
And we're using-- this
technology started in 2005.
It's 15 years in the making.
It's very much
robust, battle-tested.
And by the way,
it's open source,
so it's not just
Google who uses it.
There are many other companies.
Probably the other most
well-known one is Pokemon Go.
And I don't know if
anybody is still playing.
But it is something that
we felt really good about.
And remember when I said, we
have all the world experts?
So the guy behind this library,
Eric Veach, he's a legend here.
When he was a PhD student, he
worked on computer graphics
and his thesis was
on ray tracing.
And that algorithm is still
used in pretty much every ray
tracing software today.
He actually got Oscars for it.
If you watched
"Monsters, Incorporated,"
so that's his work.
Anyway, he just
happens to work out
of Seattle, same building,
same floor as BigQuery team is.
So when we worked
on BigQuery GIS
and we had some
tricky question, all
I had to do is stand up,
walk 20 meters, say, Eric,
how would you deal with
polygons, [INAUDIBLE]..
And he goes, oh, just
do this and that.
OK, so we will be going now
into the internals of S2.
And stay with me.
I'll explain later how we
use it inside BigQuery,
and why is it useful
and why is it good.
OK, so we'll start with
our first assumption
that Earth is round.
And we're all grown-ups here.
We of course that
this is not true.
And I don't mean that
the world is flat,
but it's not actually
a sphere, right?
It's an ellipsoid.
But you know, a sphere
is easier to work with.
And I think that all of
the biological properties
of ellipsoid are
preserved from a sphere.
Only distances become different.
So we can compensate
for it later.
OK, so let's start
with round Earth.
But first thing we do--
it's hard to index on a
sphere, so first thing we do
is say, well, what if
Earth was actually a cube?
So we draw a cube
around the Earth,
and we project every single
point to the faces of cube.
There are six of them.
And why is it simpler?
Because the faces of the
cube are actually flat.
And on a flat surface, we can
do all the arithmetic and all
the calculations
much, much easier.
OK, so how we actually project
from a sphere to a cube?
Well, for a single
point, it's very easy.
The formula is stable.
But then what
happens is when you
project an area, if it's
closer to a quarter, right
in the middle, it
will be smaller.
If you go north or
south, it becomes bigger.
And actually, the
distortion becomes
as big as five times bigger.
And this is not good if we
want to do precise indexing.
So we'll have to
do some adjustment.
Oops.
Yeah, we'll have to
do some adjustment.
Again, it becomes a little bit
tricky to do exact adjustments.
We need to do arc tangents--
and that's by the way,
the math I was referring to,
that's the end of the math--
which is very expensive.
So what S2 came up with, really
a nice quadratic approximation,
which is almost as precise as
trigonometry and almost as fast
as a linear one.
OK, so now we have a method
of projection points and areas
onto the face of the cube.
So let's take one of
the faces of the cube.
There are six of them.
So this is one.
And you see-- we
already projected.
So see how flat it is?
Because it's on a cube.
So now in order to index it,
we're going to build a tree.
And usually, in
computer science,
when people talk about trees,
they talk about binary trees.
But since it's
two-dimensional now,
we build what's
called a quad tree.
So we take the whole face and
divide it into four squares,
and then take each
one of those squares
and divide it again
into four squares.
And we do it again
and again and again.
Actually, we do it 30 times.
So we have 30
levels in our tree.
And each one of those
squares is called cube
so we have 2 to
the power of 30 2
to the power of 30, which
is 2 to the power of 60
different cells.
If you look at the cell
at the lowest level,
at the level of 30, it's
about one square centimeter.
So we have six faces.
It nicely fits into
64-bit integer.
So just think about it.
I'm working here on a sim.
And each of my steps, I'm
having hundreds of the cells,
and each one of them has unique
integer associated with it.
I think that's great.
So we're using those
integers as our indexes.
Now, to get good
special indexing--
by the way, I've often talked
about how BigQuery, everything
is gone and there
are no indexes.
So this, of course,
simplification.
Of course behind the scenes,
it uses all kinds of things,
just not visible to the user.
Which is a good
thing for the user,
because you don't have
to worry about it.
We do it for you.
So the next thing
we need to do is
to figure out how to connect
all those cells together, right?
It's two-dimensional.
And we build what is
called space filling curve.
And we use Hilbert curve here.
And nice property
of this curve is,
points which are close together
in the real world usually--
not always, but most
of the time end up
being close to each
other on this graph.
OK, for example, those two
cells are close to each other.
They will be right
next to each other.
Of course, there are exceptions.
And sorry, this is too far.
I cannot jump and show you
a couple of points which are
close in the real world but
end up being far on the Hilbert
curve.
But this is relatively rare.
So to recap, we talked round
Earth, put it into cube,
project it, put Hilbert curve.
And you may wonder,
what does this
have to do anything
with BigQuery and GIS,
and how am I going to use it?
So now I will walk you through
a real example how it's used.
OK, we're looking at a polygon.
And people from New
York will immediately
identify this polygon.
This is of course
Metropolitan Museum of Art.
So the polygon is a
little bit complex.
There are like a dozen
edges and whatnot.
And let's say what
we wanted to do--
we also have a lot
of points, and we
want to find out which
ones are inside the museum
and which ones are outside.
So to do it exactly is actually
computationally expensive.
Think if we were to
check it for every point.
So this is where we
start using our indexes.
So what we do first is we try
to find a minimal cell out
of those hierarchical
cells which
completely cover cell polygon.
So here's one.
And it also covers some area
which is not in the museum--
in fact, more than half of it.
So we say, OK--
well, we don't have
to use single integer.
Either can use--
those are four cells.
So it becomes a little better.
We can use eight cells
or we can use 16 cells.
So what BigQuery
does, every time
you have geography
object in BigQuery,
it automatically picks
the most optimal covering
over those cell
areas and determines
which one is just an integer.
And it does it free of charge.
You're not paying
anything for it.
We do it for you.
You are not paying
for storage, you're
not paying for computations.
It's all transparent.
So there is a trade
off, of course.
We don't want to use
too many indexes,
but we also don't
want to use too few.
So it depends on the shape,
it depends on how many points
you have.
I want to say we use
machine learning for that,
but we use algorithms for that.
So we build it.
So the next step is, now
you have all those points
and you need to figure
out which are inside
and which one's outside.
And now we have this
very, very fast algorithm.
Each point has it's own S2 cell.
And our object has
its own cell covering.
So all we need to do is to
compare integers to quickly
figure out which points have
absolutely no chance of being
inside polygon.
And if you think about-- and
if you have millions of them,
we can pull out a lot of
them very, very quickly.
Now of course, there will
be some false positives.
Again, I cannot show.
And plus, it doesn't work here.
There are a couple of points
which are inside cover,
outside of museum.
We'll have to check
them separately.
But hopefully, this
number is small.
So BigQuery actually
does much more than that.
It also computes the covering
of every shard of data.
And you know, if you have point
somewhere in Seattle or San
Francisco, obviously we
have no business checking
if they are in New York.
So we can very quickly prune
out all of those partitions.
And again, all of that happens
completely automatically.
But for those algorithms
to be effective,
we also want to make sure that
points which are physically
close together, they also
end up close together
inside data or BigQuery table.
And this is where the
Hilbert curve that we
talked about will be useful.
So you know how
BigQuery has clustering
which usually only works
with integers and strings?
Well, we can also do clustering
by geography-- not today,
but very soon we
will realize it.
So I'm pronouncing this.
Could I do that?
Oh, nobody from our team.
OK, it doesn't matter.
OK, I'm pronouncing
that very soon you
will be able to take your
table with geography on it
and just say, cluster bite,
and you are going to get very--
I'll skip those-- you will
get spatial clustering,
and your performance
is going to be great.
And as we saw in those
applications which
analyzed the entire
world, it's already great.
It will become even greater.
OK, so to recap today,
we looked a little bit
into how BigQuery
internals work,
and we looked at a couple of
fairly amazing applications
that people built on top of it.
And you can find, on those
links, more info about it.
And we're looking forward to
you building your application.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]